ce projet de loi vise à traiter le fait
aux deux le fléau du séparatisme
islamistes dans sa globalité en amour il
vise à protéger nos enfants du poison de
la transmission de valeurs
antirépublicaines en aval il le souhaite
poursuivre et sanctionner plus durement
ceux dont le but n'est ni plus ni moins
que de substituer à notre république un
obscurantisme france pour atteindre cet
objectif
plusieurs dispositions je porte au nom
du ministère de la justice ont été
pensés puis enrichi par les débats
parlementaires afin d'offrir les outils
nécessaires aux services d'enquêté aux
magistrats tout d'abord l'article 3 du
projet de loi fait évoluer le dispositif
relatif au fichier des auteurs
d'infractions terroristes luffy jette
nous souhaitons ainsi renforcer la lutte
contre le terrorisme
en vérifiant que toutes personnes
postulant à un emploi ou effectuant une
demande d'habilitation n'a pas été
condamné et mise en examen pour des
infractions en lien direct ou indirect
avec des activités terroristes
c'est pourquoi nous ajoutons les
infractions d'apologie et de provocation
au terrorisme à la liste de celles
donnant lieu à une inscription à ce
fichier nous souhaitons également avec
l'article 4 de ce projet de loi est la
création d'un délit de menace
séparatiste renforcer la protection des
personnes qui exercent des missions de
service public contre ceux qui par des
comportements violents menacent en
intimidant souhaite porter atteinte à
notre capacité à faire société
il est urgent que nous avons publics
lorsqu'ils sont confrontés à ces
comportements séparatistes se sache
protégés par la loi et plus
particulièrement par la création de ce
délit spécifique
ce projet de loi répond également cette
menace nouvelle qui consiste à détourner
l' usage des réseaux sociaux pour les
transformer en vecteur de diffusion de
la haine la plus décomplexée et la plus
nuisible
l'effroyable assassinat qui a coûté la
vie à samuel pâtit
doit nous conduire à l'utc qu'est-ce
qu'on contre eux cette haine
ainsi l'article 18 crée-t-il le délit de
mise en danger de la vie d'une personne
par diffusion d'informations
personnelles permettant son
identification
même si cette mise en danger n'est pas
suivi d'effet il convient de
contrecarrer la volonté de nuire à
autrui que réprime précisément ce texte
la diffusion d'informations personnelles
sur internet sera donc punis s'ils ont
les montres l'intention manifeste de
l'auteur de porter gravement atteinte à
la personne visée les députés ont ainsi
souhaité faire préciser cette intention
en indiquant que l'auteur ne pouvait
ignorer le risque auquel il exposait les
litiges enfin l'article 20 permettra
d'aligner le temps de la réponse
judiciaire au rythme des infractions
commises en ouvrant le champ de la
comparution immédiate aux auteurs de
propos incitant à la haine sur internet
l'assemblée nationale a d'ailleurs
compléter la liste des infractions
concernées afin d'appréhender un
phénomène de la haine en ligne de façon
la plus large possible
ce mode de poursuite permettra
d'apporter une réponse rapide est
nécessaire qui fait aujourd'hui défaut à
l'arsenal pénal il est impératif de
classer les spirale de haine qui
prospère aujourd'hui sur la toile et
dont les auteurs tardaient trop souvent
à être jugé cette disposition
fruit d'une large pourrait dire très
large consultation organisée avec les
professionnels du secteur de la presse
se fera en modifiant uniquement le code
de procédure pénale je ne doute pas de
la qualité de nos débats qui permettront
sans doute d'enrichir encore ce texte
que j'estime essentiel pour nous
prémunir des dérives séparatistes qui
menacent la nation et la république
je suis à présent à votre disposition
pour répondre à toutes les questions que
vous voudrez bien me poser merci
ce ministre alors madame v rien lesage
brugnaut non c'est juste je vais pas
monopoliser la parole parce que je pense
que c'est important comme tous les
sénateurs de la commission a pu poser
des questions mal à veyrier moi-même
nous nous nous avons déjà fait 50 heures
d'audition donc on essaie d'avancer sur
des choses un petit peu plus concrète me
suis né je pense que tout comme vous
nous partageons le constat et les
angoisses et inquiétudes pour l'avenir
de notre pays je pense que voilà c'est
quelque chose quand nous sommes en
responsabilité que nous devons poser
sage nous sommes assez d'accord avec ça
au fur et à mesure de nos de nos
auditions se pose quand même
régulièrement à nous et peut-être plus
particulièrement pour les articles qui
vous concerne les moyens dont vous
bénéficierez ou dont les services
bénéficieront pour pouvoir assumer cette
volonté ou cette ambition politique qui
peut être écrite dans ce texte parce que
évidemment sans moyens on peut avoir
toutes les volontés tous les désirs de
la terre on n'y arriverait pas pensez
vous avoir les moyens pour pouvoir
appliquer tous ces orientations une
question aussi est-ce que les procureurs
qui vont être concernés par un certain
nombre d'applications et et un certain
nombre d'articles nécessite la
l'investissement des procureurs est ce
que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui ils ont
suffisamment les moyens où elles sont
ils suffisamment nombreux pour pouvoir
réagir vite parce que dans un certain
nombre de domaines il faut que les réacs
son injustice soit rapide pour qu'elle
soit efficace et surtout rapide pour que
celles et ceux qui saisissent la justice
ne soit pas encore plus inquiéter avant
qu'après donc c'est un petit peu les
questions que nous nous posons sur quels
sont les moyens et pensez vous avoir les
moyens pour appliquer tous que ce texte
je souhaiterais voir venir rapidement
venir pour régler ce set
effectivement play entre guillemets
qu'est l'islamisme et dans notre pays la
même de iberia
je ne résiste pas à dire et notamment
les moyens informatiques mais c'est
juste pour faire référence à d'autres
débats
personnellement moi je voudrais vous
poser une question sur le fige est avec
le fait qu' il puisse y avoir une
inscription automatique et au niveau de
cette inversion donc avec l'inscription
automatique
avant condamnation
comme lorsqu'on a discuté du fis ges
c'est à dire le fichier sur les
violences sexuelles
nous avons procédé là aussi à 7
on a nous avons interverti l'ordre par
contre ça nous a été refusé sur les
délits et nous n'avons pu intervertir et
donc inscrire au figés sd la mise en
examen que sur les crimes
donc je me demande si ce qui nous est
arrivé sur le fige s est ce que pas de
nous arriver sur le fige est donc c'est
petite question parallélisme des formes
par ailleurs sur les articles 18 et 20
donc voilà l'article 18 forcément nous
allons nous poser quelques questions
notamment
est ce que il n'y a pas un risque pour
le coup de deux d'autocensure et
d'applications extensive a priori
s'agissant de la diffusion d'image c'est
une question à laquelle vous vous allez
nous répondre j'imagine bien mais
surtout pour le coup sur l'article 20
est ce que dans le cas de comparution
immédiate qui déroge à la loi de 1881 1
sont-elles suffisamment encadré merci
voilà peut-être que je peux dès la
parole tout de suite monsieur le et qui
revêt la demande est pourri merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre sur collègues j'avais une
question vous posez monsieur le ministre
qui est assez général et qui fliquent
dix se trouvent en fait que dans nos
institutions
votre ministère comme le sénat sont
particulièrement attachés à la défense
des libertés publiques et c'est plus que
la tradition c'est aussi nos
respectivement nos fonctions
constitutionnelles qui le veulent et il
se trouve qu'il ya une disposition dans
le projet de loi qui veut
permettre aux préfets de continuer de
fermer des lieux de culte sous la
procédure administrative en souvent on
envisage l'intervention du juge
judiciaire dans le rempart en pareil cas
comment considérez-vous que le juge
judiciaire qui est dans le dualisme
juridictionnelle français celui qui
défend davantage les libertés publiques
petits pas que j'imite ratisse ne
voulait pas mais enfin là aussi
traditionnellement c'est plutôt lui qui
le fait comment est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que le juge judiciaire
interviennent et fasse que ces décisions
de fermeture de lieux qu il soit
prennent pleinement prises en préservant
au maximum et la liberté individuelle et
collective qui est la liberté de culte
et si la décision doit être prise
qu'elle puisse l'être prise par une
autorité totalement indépendante et qui
serait l'autorité judiciaire le cas
échéant
merci madame madame de la gontrie
merci président monsieur ministre
j'aurais souhaité que vous puissiez nous
éclairer sur sur deux points le premier
concerne l'article 18
j'ai interrogé le ministre de
l'intérieur à l'instant puisque cet
article 18
souvent été évoqué comme ne devant pas
être la réponse à la problématique posée
par l'article 24 de la proposition de
loi sur la sécurité globale
article 24 qui a connu beaucoup de
péripéties et dont nous ne savons pas
encore à cette heure quelle sera sa
réaction au final n'empêche coeur cet
article 24 et l'article 18 peuvent se
trouver en situation de concours
d'infractions et donc rendre difficile
pour dire les choses de manière le fait
mystique la définition précise de
l'arctique qui sera applicable dans le
cas des infractions concernées donc
j'aimerais savoir comment vous envisagez
l'articulation future de ces deux textes
puisque au bout du compte sauf à ce
qu'un des deux articles soit abrogée
il va bien falloir que ces deux textes
s'articule puisqu'ils vont tous deux se
trouvaient dans le code pénal
le deuxième point c'est sur l'article 20
l'article 20 il prévoit donc de
permettre l'application des procédures
dites rapides notamment comparution
immédiate mais pas que à certains délits
de presse
il faut savoir précise aux collègues que
traditionnellement la comparution
immédiate en tout cas ne s'applique
jamais aux délits de presse et aux
mineurs donc ici nous sommes dans un cas
d'exception sur lequel d'ailleurs on
peut s'interroger c'est à dire que cette
cette protection intangible que pose la
loi de 1881 me semble devoir être
préservé et je crains la taille qui est
fait avec ce processus mais au-delà de
cela
j'aimerais avoir quelques
éclaircissements parce qu'au bout du
bout je n'ai pas très bien compris
ou plutôt je n'ai pas très bien
identifier quels étaient les infractions
qu'ils allaient pouvoir être poursuivis
de ce chef
ou plutôt pas de ce chef sur cette
procédure sachant qu' il y a déjà toute
une série de dispositions existantes et
comme même si je pense que le texte de
l'assemblée a peut-être arranger les
choses comme il ya eu également des
commentaires indiquant que pour certains
cas ça ne pourrait être applicable qu'en
cas de flagrance finalement une certaine
modification est intervenue je crois à
l'assemblée pour corriger ce point au
bout du compte je ne sais plus très
exactement quelle est l'utilité pratique
du texte et si j insiste c'est qu'on
pourrait se satisfaire finalement d'un
texte qui ne sert à rien mais évidemment
ça ne peut pas être l'objectif mais
surtout et je reviens à mon prochain
point initial je pense que c'est
problématique de porter atteinte à la
loi de 1881 parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on pense souvent
ce n'est pas un texte qui protège
simplement la liberté de la presse
c'est un texte qui protège la liberté
d'expression et donc les règles qui sont
applicables sont très importantes et on
sait que la procédure d'urgence existent
également dans la loi 10
80 nous sommes ici des élus nous avons
peut-être eu à connaître de la procédure
d'urgence spécifiques lorsque des
infractions sont commises en période
électorale et qui permette qu'un
tribunal correctionnel se prononce dans
les 48 heures en cas d'infraction à la
loi sur la presse donc voila un petit
peu les éclaircissements qui mute était
utile d'entendre de votre part merci
madame un merdier
ce qui m'a intéressé essentiellement
c'était le la protection du consommateur
du consentement des futurs époux on est
dans un tout autre registre afin de
lutter contre les mariages forcés
c'est une disposition de bon sens c'est
une disposition pour éviter que l'on se
serve de du mariage pour justement
profité de deux
d'une femme qui pourrait être vulnérable
alors je voudrais revenir parce que je
suis de tourcoing vous le savez et on a
souvent eu des cas comme ça de mariage
soit forcé soit blanc soit et ont saisi
le procureur
l'article 17 à parler justement de de
prévention en obligeant l'officier
d'état civil qui doute sur un mariage à
saisir le procureur de la république
c'est déjà le cas quand on a des doutes
on saisit procureur mais ce qu'on
constate très souvent c'est que c'est
bon pour une fois mais tout simplement
ben les personnes sur présente ailleurs
ça représente dans d'autres villes
à d'autres moments à d'autres instants
avec des officiers d'état civil qui sont
moins vigilants et on sait très bien
qu'à la fin du défunt ben
ce qui avait été prévu se réalise parce
que je voudrais savoir monsieur le
ministre
est ce que au niveau géographique on
pourrait avoir un regard parce que là en
l'occurrence on parle de commune par
commune
mais avez-vous possibilité d'avoir des
dispositions pour procureur d'avoir un
regard plus globale parce que sinon bah
c'est ça sert à rien d'être d'empêcher
un jour j et le lendemain à pouvoir le
faire ailleurs
jourdas
merci monsieur président gestion un peu
sémantique monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous avez évoqué verbalement mais c'est
a également écrit ainsi dans le texte la
lutte contre la haine en ligne la haine
est un sentiment nous nous subissons
plus que nous ne maîtrisons nos
sentiments l'état va-t-il nous interdire
de haïr ou de haies mais je pense que
tel n'est pas le cas de cette
proposition de ce projet de loi pardon
en conséquence était bien judicieux
d'utiliser ces termes dans la loi merci
voilà
et puis monsieur philippe bas merci
beaucoup monsieur le président puisque
nous avons la chance d'avoir le garde
des sceaux
tu voudrais lui poser une question
excusez moi je lui dise oui puisque nous
avons la chance de vous avoir voudrais
vous poser une question de droit pénal
moi je ne suis pas pénaliste je voulais
vous demander si l'article 35 de la loi
du 9 décembre 1905 la loi de séparation
des églises et de l'état pouvait être
appliquée aux provocations directes à
résister à l'exécution des lois qui sont
commises par des imams salafistes dans
les mosquées
je vous rappelle cet article si un
discours prononcé ou un écrit affiches
et distribuer publiquement dans les
lieux où s'exerce le culte contient une
provocation directe à résister à
l'exécution des lois aux actes légaux de
l'autorité publique je continue la
lecture
le ministre des cultes qui s'en sera
rendue coupable sera puni d'un
emprisonnement de 3 mois 2 ans sans
préjudice des peines de la complicité
dans le cas où la provocation aurait été
suivie d'une sédition révolte ou guerre
civile
je voudrais savoir monsieur le ministre
si ça permet bien de poursuivre un imam
salafiste qui dans une mosquée ferait ce
genre de provocations et si c'est le cas
est-ce que les procureurs en gage de
telles poursuites
quelle est la statistique que vous
pourriez avoir pour nous dire si cet
article de la loi de 1905 est bel et
bien appliquée et quels sont les
instructions vous donnez aux procureurs
à cet égard oui monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole alors je vais
essayer de vous répond d'abord à
monsieur le sénateur philippe bas
dérogeant ainsi à l'ordre chronologique
des questions qui m'ont été posées
bon ça commence bien vite on a la chance
d'avoir le ministre de la justice c'est
un mot aimable
ensuite vous poser une question à
laquelle vous avez dû réfléchir
longtemps longtemps et vous voudriez que
je vous réponde tout de suite
excipant du fait que vous n'êtes pas un
pénaliste qualité que vous m'attribuez
je sus pénaliste mais je ne suis pas le
dalloz alors je vais réfléchir votre
question monsieur le sénateur vous
connaissez le chemin de la chancellerie
vous y êtes déjà venu vous êtes conviés
à me rencontrer à nouveau et je vous
répondrai très précisément à cette
question particulièrement technique à
laquelle je ne m'attendais pas il ne
vous a pas échappé que si je suis garde
des sceaux je ne suis pas ministre des
cultes
voilà mes réponses elle n'est pas
satisfaisante
vous ressortirez lycée avec une
véritable frustration mais vous en
guérir et lorsque nous nous
rencontrerons prochainement à la chanson
c'est cette réponse pourrait être
collectif parce que c'est une question
que j'ai posée à monsieur darmanin tout
à l'heure qu'est ce qu'il a dit monsieur
germain qui pour le coup est le
des cultes oui justement mais c'est pour
ça qu'il était très intéressant d'avoir
la réponse du ministre de la justice a
annoncé qu'ils pouvaient différer de
celle des ministres
mais moi je n'ai aucun problème pour
répondre à cette question mais dois je
vous réponds tu dois je vous répondre
mais peut-être même de la gontrie au qui
avait été avocate vous connaissez la
réponse si vous mon souffle et une jeu
la reprendre à mon compte si elle existe
un
c'est bien c'est bon côté moi je préfère
ne rien dire que de raconter des choses
qui qui qui voit là sur lesquelles je
reste je n'ai pas je n'ai pas réfléchi
monsieur bas et donc mais très
sincèrement au delà c'est vital de la
boutade amical que je vous adresse prix
venez on va regarder cette question et
vous préoccupez il est légitime que le
garde des sceaux puisse y répond
monsieur monsieur monsieur philippe bas
monsieur le ministre je veux juste te
dire je veux vous dire je veux juste
vous dire que votre réponse est déjà
extrêmement intéressante
1 oui parce que le garde des sceaux
n'est pas en mesure de nous dire si la
disposition nous je parle répressive
principal pour les provocations directes
à résister à l'exécution des lois joue
dans une mosquée peuvent ou non faire
l'objet de poursuites aujourd'hui ce qui
est quand même singulier mais non quand
on vient défendre monsieur loi sur le
scénario même si le sénateur la
pardonnez moi
bon vous pouvez jouer et cela c'est
facile moi je peux vous avoir sur
d'autres sujets si nous inversions les
rôles pourrait vous poser un certain
nombre de questions sur des chartes et
je ne suis pas qu'un devoir être
ministre et vous êtes sénateur depuis
longtemps pardon je vous être sérieux là
moi j'entends répondre à toutes les
questions je me prêterait volontiers à
cet exercice qui est parfaitement
légitime mais vous venez me chercher sur
un texte
je n'y ai pas réfléchi je vous dit sur
le ton de la boutade amical que je suis
tout à fait disposé à ce que nous en
parlions si cela vous préoccupe
je pense que si vous m'en parlez ce
qu'il y a derrière tout cela une
légitime préoccupation laquelle je
souhaite répond maintenant je n'ai pas
quatre ans je ne suis pas
dans la cour de récréation d'une école
vous n'êtes pas mon instituteur on va
pas faire du bourg bain quel est le prix
du ticket de métro ben ouais je préfère
ne pas répondre que de vous dire des
âneries mais je vais réfléchir à la
question et je vous répondrai le plus
complètement possible et si mes services
peuvent dès à présent vous répondre ils
me feront passer la note je vous la
dirai et je vous rassure m je vous
promets qu'il y aura une réponse à cette
question qui vous tient tellement à
coeur elle n'est pas secondaire monsieur
le ministre l état qu elle n'est pas
secondaire
je ne tirez pas de mon silence de cet
instant je ne sais quelle conclusion
c'est une non-réponse voile avait et
puis quand même vous faire remarquer
gentiment que sentiments naturellement
je vous être toujours gentil avez-vous
nous périmètre d'intervention sur ce
texte divisait les articles dont j'ai
parlé très bien ils sont limités bon
maintenant on pouvait m'interroger sur
tout ce que vous voulez et c'est la
démonstration c'est de ne pas obtenir de
réponse
ce n'est pas le but alors je vous
répondrais vous viendrez me voir je vous
répondrai alors s'il veut répondre aux
questions auxquelles je je pense pouvoir
répondre par donc allez-y d'abord celle
qui m'est posée par madame la
rapporteure jacques une star brignon sur
les moyens au fond c'est une vraie
question
prendre un beau texte et ne pas pouvoir
le mettre à exécution
c'est un non sens qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans mon périmètre fige est franchement
ça ne manque pas de moyens on inscrit en
inscrire pas article 4 article 18 se
font des textes sont les infractions
peuvent être jugées devant les
juridictions pas non plus près compléter
la haine en ligne ça peut l'être un peu
plus et pour les non ligne vous savez
qu'il y avait une plateforme police et
que nous avons créé un pôle n en ligne
pour lutter contre la haine en ligne au
parquet de paris
trois magistrats ils sont d'ores et déjà
dédiés et ce n'est pas une compétence
exclusive
et pour le moment de l' expertise que
nous avons le nombre de magistrats est
suffisant bien sûr vous avez compris est
une évidence ça n'aura pas vocation à
traiter toutes les expressions et nous
en ligne il y en a des millions
malheureusement ce que j'ai souhaité
faire en créant cet article 20 dont bien
sûr je vous reparlerai plus longuement
et précisément c'est surtout pour les
jeunes d'ailleurs qu'ils utilisent cet
outil comme un vecteur de n avoir une
comparution immédiate qui puisse être
susceptible de générer l'exemple autant
je ne crois pas forcément dans
l'exemplarité des peines quand il s'agit
de délinquants chevronnés et comme le
rappelait d'ailleurs robert badinter
quand on commet une infraction c'est pas
être le code pénal sous le bras autant
pour des gamins c'est important parce
que ils sauront ils devront savoir et
certains les prouveront devant la
juridiction correctionnelle qu'on ne
peut plus raconter n'importe quoi
c'est le sens du texte et je les y
revenir dans un instant madame la
rapporteur dominique vivien donc posé la
question sur le fige est moi d'abord
d'abord quand vous évoquez la diffusion
d'image il s'agit dans le texte de
diffuser des informations personnelles
susceptibles 2 il faut quand même
apporté cette précision et je vous
donnerai dans un instant d'autres
précisions sur les fige est sûre le fige
est et sur les préoccupations qui sont
les vôtres puisque vous avez comparé
avec l'autre fichiers mais je pense qu
ici on évoque le terrorisme je pense que
l'écueil que vous évoquez au fond est
suffisamment illusoire pour que nous
allions plus avant dans ce texte
monsieur loïc avez vous monsieur le
sénateur pardon vous que vous vous avez
évoqué les lieux cultes fermeture c'est
une question sur l'intervention du juge
judiciaire ou du juge administratif en
matière de liberté de culte
vous connaissez le dualisme
juridictionnelle et qu'il n'est pas
question de remettre en cause chaque
ordre est compétent dans son domaine au
service des libertés publiques vous
pouvez être rassurés par le juge
administratif comme garant de nos
libertés
madame ont pris d'abord la sénatrice je
voudrais vous expliquer l'article 20
parce que les craintes que vous évoquez
quant à la liberté de la presse n'ont
pas de raison d'être
je veux dire pourquoi l'article
ce qui réprime la haine en ligne c'est
la haine on line c'est l'article 24 de
la loi de 1881 il y avait deux solutions
ou toucher à la loi de 1881
elle est aux techniques vous savez et la
presse se serait inquiété de cela et
légitimement j'ai réuni j'ai dit dans
mon discours liminaire tous les organes
de presse syndicats de journalistes
patrons de presse
avocat spécialisé tous m'ont dit on
touche pas 10 880 même si par le passé
passé récent d'ailleurs on y a déjà
touché à quelques reprises l'idée
c'était donc de régler l'équation
suivante des diamants qui diffuse la
haine en ligne je le dis tout à l'heure
c'est souvent des jeunes ça n'est un
mystère pour personne bénéficie de la
protection de la loi de 1881 qui n'a pas
été fait pour eux elle a été fait pour
les journalistes c'est la protection non
non non et laissez-moi réponse et si si
si elle a été faite à l'origine en 1881
et on l'appelle la loi c'est la loi de
la presse pour pour les journalistes
très bien et il ya un certain nombre de
haineux du quotidien qui viennent se
loger dans la loi de 1881 et qui
bénéficie donc des protections
procédurales accordée aux journalistes
pour une espèce d'impunité et si ce
n'est pas une impunité
c'est une décision de justice qui sera
rendu bien plus tard devant forcément
devant la chambre spécialisée
c'est d'ailleurs une revendication des
journalistes qui disent nous sur une
infraction ne pouvons pas être jugé dans
l'immédiateté
il faut avoir du recul nous avons besoin
d'échanger un certain nombre de pièces
notamment et nous savons qu'un
journaliste quand il est poursuivi il
n'est pas jugée avant un an et demi de
18 mois voilà mais vous dites non
écoutez madame je ne vous ai pas
interrompu tout à l'heure les laissez
moi développer mes arguments vous aurez
le droit c'est la démocratie de ne pas
être d'accord avec ça mais c'est ce que
j'ai recueillis au terme d'une très
longue consultation je vous en donnerai
le détail si vous voulez j'ai reçu tout
le monde
alors la question c'était puisque je ne
peux pas et que je ne veux pas cacher
été convaincu par les journalistes par
les syndicats par les avocats que je ne
veux pas toucher à la loi de 1881 je
vais toucher en réalité à la procédure
pénale et je vais faire en sorte que les
noeuds du quotidien il soit
immédiatement jugé en comparution
immédiate et je pense que pour les
gamins notamment l'exemplarité elle est
au coeur de cette disposition
voilà ce que je pense vous avez bien sûr
le droit et je le conçois de ne pas être
d'accord avec moi
ensuite vous ne posez une autre question
à laquelle je ne pourrais pas répondre
mais pour des raisons différentes que
celles que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
devant monsieur auprès de monsieur le
sénateur bas c'est le télescopage au
fond entre 24 et 18 bat déjà donnez moi
la mouture de 24 que vous êtes entendre
et écrire c'est vous tirez la main sur
24 mois j'ai préparé 18
j'ai préparé 18 comment les choses
peuvent s'articuler nous nous nous en
parlerons il faudra puisque nous sommes
dans le débat parlementaire
excusez moi vous dire que il y aura
forcément forcément n'est nécessairement
une solution qui sera prouvée et partie
sera t-elle trouvé mal à me la sénatrice
de la gontrie bhl par vous il n'est pas
avare dit
moi je propose un texte on va faire en
sorte que ces textes ne soient pas dans
l'opposition c'est quand même un comble
mais qu'il soit l'un et l'autre et s'il
faudra que et si vous estimez qu'il faut
il faut bouger pas pardon pour ce
possessive mon article 18
vous vous le ferez ce n'est pas à moi à
cet instant précis ça n'est pas moi qui
peut répondre à cette question
madame la sénatrice lherbier vous me
demandez au fond pardon si on peut
assurer un suivi de ce qu'ils veulent
non d'abord je je je pense que c'est une
question évidemment intéressante parce
que vous avez raison certains passent
d'une mairie à l'autre alors alors je
vous fais respectueusement remarquer que
ça ça n'est pas mon périmètre vous aviez
marlène schiappa qui se charge elle de
porter ces ces mesures qui ont été
rédigées c'est vrai par les services de
la chancellerie mais c'est elle qui les
portent mais ça n'est pas une réponse
suffisante je l'entends bien c'est une
interrogation légitime
c'est une interrogation d'autant plus
légitime que ce que vous dites serait
efficace
peut-on le mettre en place franchement
je ne sais pas et de ne sais pas comment
on pourrait assurer ce suivi d'une
espèce de nouveaux fichiers que nous
créerions qui serait le fichier des
mariages forcés et comment on va les
diffuser comment on fait peut réfléchir
à cette question je peux si vraiment
vous souhaitez qu'on aille plus avant
dans cette question ils travaillaient
ensemble je n'y suis pas hostile du tout
mais à cet instant précis je suis
incapable de vous en dire davantage
j'ai demandé la tatane précieux
sans répondre à regarder sur le ring
messieurs tout simplement pour essayer
de trouver de l'efficacité au texte on
en propose parce qu'on sait entre
roubaix tourcoing et d'autres villes je
sais il ya plein de sujets comme ça où
nous occupons lui est efficace il faut
dès le départ à voir tu connais
organisation madame lherbier j'ai cru
comprendre que à travers votre question
il fallait vous interroger sur le fait
que les parquets apporte une réponse
cohérente enfin j'ai des dires homogène
plus exactement sur l'ensemble du
territoire et qu'elle est elle plutôt la
façon dont le ministre en charge de la
justice pouvait sensibiliser ses
parquets et ses procureurs sur ce point
là si j'ai cru comprendre que c'était la
question c'est la communication à ce que
sylvain parent dont j'imagine un instant
je n'y ai pas réfléchi que l'on demande
au procureur par voie de circulaire par
exemple de mais comment vont-ils
communiquer les informations est ce que
il faut une communication nationale mais
moi je suis prêt à travailler sur cette
question avec vous parce que je pense
qu'elle est opportune en termes
d'efficacité
pas question qu à tourcoing ont refusé
qu'on aille se marièrent ou b oui mais
on peut on peut régler ça par voie de
circulaire en demandant à ce que les
parcs et diffuse un certain nombre
d'informations mais on crée alors une
espèce de fichier national pour pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas il faut le faire
expertiser moi je me dis pas non madame
la sénatrice muriel jourda
oui vous aurez encore le droit de haïr
je veux vous rassurer pourquoi ce moore
pourquoi ce mot parce que c'est le mot
de la loi seront puni des peines prévues
à l'alinéa précédent ce qui par ces
mêmes moyens auront provoqué à la haine
et moi je sors de ce texte sur le
terrain de la procédure pénale
parce que c'est bien cette peine naquit
à vos questions s'appliquer je veux pas
utiliser un autre mot ma référence c'est
l'article 24 2
digi 180 alors le législateur de
l'époque d'ailleurs qui n'est pas le
législateur de 1881 puisqu'on a modifié
le texte je les dis la haine en ligne ça
a été forcément modifié récemment parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas de réseaux sociaux
en 1880 tout le monde le sait mais c'est
le modem qui a été choisi alors je
comprends qu'il ne vous plaisent tom
pouvait pas choisir un autre nom mais
c'est une question de sémantique m'avez
vous dis non et ben je vous réponds j'ai
pris le mou qui se trouve dans la loi
nous avons fait pas grief la 6ème chaîne
ministre je devrais je rassurais sur les
dispositions du nouvel article 24 dans
le texte sécurité globale en réalité la
commission des lois a voté ce matin 1 1
9e un nouvel article 24
pour ne rien vous cacher nous avons
supprimé la rédaction qui était qui
arrivait de l'assemblée nationale et qui
a été polémique pour rédiger un article
au terme duquel nous avons essayé de
régler le problème de supprimer la
notion de publication en réalité pour la
remplacer par la notion de provocation
qui permet de mieux répondre
à la ola l'objet à l'objectif poursuivi
à savoir de protéger les policiers
municipaux les gendarmes ou les
policiers nationaux dans l'exercice de
leurs missions des agressions dont ils
pourraient faire l'objet singulièrement
par la voix de la publication de leurs
images sur internet nourrit ensuite par
d'autres à la fois de leur état civil de
leur adresse et qui permettent ainsi un
certain nombre de personnes qui leur
veulent du mal et qui souhaitent
commettre un délit ou un crime de
pouvoir les îles agir et donc le texte
est modifié de la sorte
il est donc un caractère spécifique
naturellement cette provocation nous
l'avons élargi aux proches à la famille
pour faire très court et nous avons
complété cet article d'un troisième
alinéa pour répondre à la préconisation
de la cnil en ce qui concerne
d'effectivement l'interdiction de ce
type de fichier qui se constitue
j'allais dire de façon un peu erratique
sur les réseaux et de manière à ce qu'on
puisse les faire supprimer le plus
rapidement possible donc voilà la
manière dont nous avons rédigé cet
article
l'intérêt de cette nouvelle rédaction
parce que nous allons défendre la
position du sénat ans le français ans
bien sûr la semaine prochaine mais dans
quinze jours c'est d'avoir par rapport à
l'article 24 du texte confortement des
valeurs de la république
une incrimination spécifique qui vise à
protéger spécifiquement les policiers
nationaux gendarmes et policiers
municipaux
l'article 24 que vous portez à karachi
xs alors on est sorti aussi je vous le
dis de la loi de 1881 nous nous sommes
fondés sur le code pénal naturellement
de manière à éviter aussi les
difficultés rencontrées au moment où cet
amendement a été voté à l'assemblée
nationale et singulièrement avec le
monde de la presse et enfin sur
l'article 24 qui est que vous portez il
est de nature plus large et
et permet de 18 à 25 révisé 18 18 18 et
petites précisions sur cette question ce
n'est pas après la sémantique la
numérologie mais il y avait le 24 de la
loi de la proposition fauvel fauvergue
ça que vous avez retravailler il ya le
24 de la loi de 1881 l'article 18 que je
porte de l'enclos
c'était l'article 23 dans le projet
initial
quand ladite 18 on va penser que c'est
juste avant 24e mais c'est pas dans le
même projet le ppl et et projet de loi
il est venu 18 pour cette raison les
précisions mérite d'être fait parce que
parfois enfin à l'extérieur et à un
certain nombre de confusion dont nous
avons entendu les co merci monsieur le
président de de m'informer sur le 24 on
va voir si 24 et 18 sont désormais
compatibles nous aurons évidemment ce
débat et monsieur le sénateur bah je
vais pouvoir vous satisfaire mais
partiellement
voilà les dispositions vous évoquez
l'article 35 ne vous posez plus la
question de savoir comment les procurent
à vous il est abrogé il est abrogé par
le pôle paix pardon si vous votez le
texte il est il est allongé les les
dispositions du texte que nous
présentons auront pour effet d'abroger
la disposition qui vous dont
l'application vous taraude et tout à
l'heure si vous me permettez 6 mai oui
s'il est abrogé voilà c'est une pop
je chante et je vais user mois puisque
vous en reparler c'est un problème
politique il ya une disposition qui
permet de l'infliger jusqu'à deux ans de
prison à un ministre du culte qui fait
des provocations a violé la loi mais je
me dis est ce que cette disposition qui
est quand même une dispositions
répressives assez forte est appliquée ou
non dans notre république parce qu'avant
de changer les lois
il faut quand même s'interroger son
poids de savoir si les armes dont nous
disposons les armes pénales sont oui ou
non appliquées si des consignes sont
régulièrement donnée au procureur pour
les appliquer j'entends bien que la
question ne se posera plus quand on aura
changé la loi mais c'est quand même
intéressant avant de changer la loi de
savoir si les instruments temps nous
disposons sur oui ou non appliquées
c'est juste le sens de ma question et je
ne vais pas poser pour vous embarrasser
je vous assure bien ajouté un but plein
boum je vais aller la prise ou répondre
on va y arriver
madame v rien monsieur minispace que
pour compléter sur le sujet je comprends
pas ce que je j'avoue avoir fait naître
le débat puisque j'ai posé cette
question effectivement à monsieur
darmanin qui nous a répondu que ça
n'avait c'est pour ça que je vais vous
faciliter la réponse que ça n'avait
jamais été employée et parce que
justement il disait que c'était je sais
plus mais en cas de sédition voilà or
est-ce que sédition peut pas l'entendre
comme séparatisme et du coup est ce que
justement on n'aurait pas pu malgré tout
employé c'était sa mère du coup ça de ça
devient mais effectivement je vous
réponds puisque ça n'a jamais été
employée et on se dit pourquoi ça n'a
jamais été employée est en fait il est
effectivement supprimés mais il est
supprimé pour être étendue et est ce qu
on l'appliquera plus après qu'avant
puisque globalement on modifie pas tant
que ça voit la petite madame de la
gontrie a demandé la parole oui
je voulais mais sans mais le sang sans
prolonger à l'excès le sujet mais parce
que je recherche la bonne solution parce
que j'entends ce que vous recherchez
concernant l'article 20 vous faites à
plusieurs reprises vous avez fait
référence en utilisant l'expression des
gamins est ce que ça veut donc dire que
cet article s'appliquerait également aux
mineurs ou pas et du coup nous nous
trouverions devant une deuxième
exception
c'est à dire une comparution immédiate
qui non seulement s'appliquerait à skis
relevé jusqu'à présent de la loi sur la
presse mais qui s'appliquerait également
aux mineurs cela étant la loi sur la
presse
vous le savez porte je le répète sur
l'ensemble de ce qui peut comment dire
encadré encadrer l'exercice de la
liberté d'expression puisque nous le
savons tous la diffamation et cetera il
s'agit d'autre chose que de la presse
s'agit de n'importe quel propos tenus
publiquement le seul critère au fond
c'est le caractère public
si je relève ce point c'est que je le
répète la loi sur la presse prévoit déjà
un mécanisme d'urgence c'est l'article
54 et que si votre objectif c'est
effectivement de permettre des décisions
rapides
il n'était pas nécessaire d'avoir
recours à la comparution immédiate
vous pouviez trouver une solution à
l'intérieur de la loi de 1881 bien
monsieur nous avons préféré le mie
câline de la comparution immédiate
qui est un mécanisme ultra rapide vous
me reparler madame la sénatrice de
liberté d'expression il ya évidemment la
liberté d'expression que l'on ne peut
pas confondre avec ce qui est dit par
les usurpateurs de liberté et ceux qui
diffusent la haine et en particulier la
haine en ligne voilà pourquoi il nous
est apparu et nous avons évidemment
longuement réfléchi mais l'exemplarité
est un des fondements de notre démarche
nous avons pensé qu effectivement plutôt
que d'être jugé dans 18 mois il était
nécessaire que l'on soit jugé
immédiatement il ne vous a pas échappé
également que la comparution immédiate
permettent aussi un certain nombre de
mesures qui ne sont pas permises
si nous ne sommes pas dans une
comparution immédiate
voilà pourquoi nous avons choisi la
bien je voudrais peut-être pour
clarifier les choses
quant à l'article 54 si vous le lisez il
ne permet pas de mesures de sûreté car
il est fait pour les journalistes que
nous voulions nous mais dit non tout à
l'heure à plusieurs reprises longtemps
dû mais cette loi de 1881 il fait pour
protéger la presse pas pour protéger les
types qui répandent la haine dans notre
pays mais y'en a marre de cette semaine
en ligne si vous voulez qu'on ne fasse
rien ce que je ne peux pas croire
l'ombre de long d'une seconde
mais voilà on va pas protéger des gens
qui est joli autre chose de moi
madame la sénatrice si je vous dis le
fond de ma pensée je voulais aussi tapé
bien sûr ceux qui sont devenus des
professionnels de la haine en ligne et
nous en connaissons mais leur statut est
tel que ils sont protégés par la loi de
1881 et détricoté pour eux c'était
donner un très mauvais signal à la fred
très très grande majorité des
journalistes qui dans notre pays
respecte évidemment les valeurs
républicaines et ne sont pas des noeuds
et pour que lequel est pour quelques
exceptions ne l'avions pas détricoter
1881 c'est pour ça qu'on est allé sur
une modification de la procédure pénale
mais cinq ans
prix 15 et franchement moi je suis
absolument convaincu que quand on dira
pas ce que c'est ça le message à nos
jeunes que si on raconte n'importe quoi
on peut se retrouver du jour au
lendemain devant le tribunal
correctionnel
je ne dis pas que ça va tout arranger je
n'ai pas de baguette magique mais je
pense que ça peut arranger un certain
nombre de choses et si déjà ça diminue
un peu et bien nous aurons gagné le pari
qui est le nôtre et que nous nous sommes
imposés dans cette réflexion
merci monsieur je voudrais revenir
quelques instants mais pour que les
choses soient bien claires entre nous
sur les dispositions de l'article 35 de
la loi de 1905
l'article 35 dispose si un discours
prononcé ou un écrit afficher ou
distribués publiquement dans les lieux
où s'exerce le culte contient une
provocation directe à résister à
l'exécution des lois ou à actes légaux
de l'autorité publique ou s'il tend à
soulever ou a armé une partie des
citoyens contre les autres le ministre
du culte qui s'en sera rendue coupable
sera puni d'un emprisonnement de trois
ans à deux ans sans préjudice des peines
de la complicité dans le cas où la
provocation ont été suivies d'une
sédition révolte aux guerres civiles
ce texte qui est un texte donc qui
sanctionne la question posée est at il
déjà été appliquée en l'état il
semblerait que non mais c'est ce que
nous a dit le ministre de l'intérieur
mais peut-être que du côté de la
chancellerie
les informations judiciaires sont
peut-être plus précise est en fait
monsieur le ministre si vous pouviez
dicillo de la séance regardez cette
information vérifiée la formation qu'il
a été donné de manière à ce qu'on sache
ni plus ni moins car la question de fond
qui existe c'est s'il n'a pas été
utilisé pas par vous ou mais mais mais
pourquoi voilà
ce qui ne change rien à l'invitation
monsieur sénateurs que je vous ai lancé
mais il semble effectivement le ministre
de l'intérieur qui s'exprimait au
conditionnel parce qu'on n'a pas les
mêmes oui on n'a pas les mêmes l'esthète
fait les mêmes données dont les données
qui semblent être les nôtres 0 on n'a
jamais utilisé le pressent donc voilà
c'est bien que le ministre l'intérieur
une liste de la justice disent la même
chose bien mieux aux conditions et
conditionnel prudent et l'autre dit
après avoir vérifié auprès des services
que ça ça semble ne jamais avoir été
utilisé voilà bien les choses sont ainsi
clarifié
[Musique]